un día final muy movido en el mercado de
fichajes europeo sobre todo para el
bayern munich y para el manchester
united
los alemanes se confirmaron tres
fichajes el regreso del brasileño de
unas costas la llegada de maxim choupo
moting verde psc y el lateral francés e
por una sartén barcella a ese club
los bávaros transfirieron al
centrocampista mikel y sants mientras
que el united confirmó cuatro
incorporaciones edinson cavani el
delantero libre del psc el defensor
alexis tse se deportó y dos promesas el
uruguayo facundo félix tri de peñarol y
el marfileño adaptadores de atalanta que
se sumará en enero entre los pases
destacados aparece en pantalla el
atlético madrid y torreira han
arsenal-barcelona deja ir a rafinha y
ato divo bakayoko se suman a poli smolin
aroma kluivert pasa a herbalife siquiera
se suma a juventus que a su vez se da de
siglo al lyon y el brasileño rafinha
pasa de rehén a la élite